thank you so much for watching so are
you sorry I just had I always believed
that Knoxville talent can can take you
so far the most pressure I feel is the
pressure that I put on myself yeah I
mean everyone's gonna have bad days and
no one's perfect and everyone's going to
make mistakes make a good decision make
a good swing the end result will take
care of itself so instead of Sam I want
to win the Masters I'll say what will
help me when the Masters don't let
anyone tell you that you come I think
the most important thing for an athlete
is building their brand on their
performance it's trying to be the best
golfer I can be but at the same time you
know not letting that take over my life
I feel like the game's given me a lot
and you know I'd love to give some back
people ask me what's it like you know
living this life what's it like to be
Roy McLeroy uh you know I'm living like
my dream this is what I've always
dreamed of he's a Northern Irish
professional golfer he was the world
number one golfer for 95 weeks
in 2012 he became the youngest ever
professional golfer to reach ten million
dollars in career earnings
he's Rory McIlroy and here are his top
ten rules for success I always believe
that natural talent can can take you so
far but I think you need to have the
work ethic and the drive to to achieve
your potential I mean I'd say you know
my natural talent you know probably
brought me 50% of the way but then after
that it was all it was all done to the
work that I've done and the volume of
work that I've done over the you know
the last 15 years you know when I really
started to take gold seriously and you
know thought about you making this a
career
and 154 just in the intermediate cut
here all slightly above his feet should
help him turn a little right to left
which is his shot shape anyway as a rule
well he's just hit a monster high ball
see where this comes down it was
straight up it shot Roger another one of
those laser iron shots right at it that
just falls like a beanbag on the green
Roger this now McIlroy for birdie and
the outright lead so McAvoy with a 333
at 6 takes a one-stroke lead at 19-under
par and Rory McIlroy survives the two in
the second
to work class for the FedExCup pressure
is a funny thing I think there's two
types of pressure there's pressure that
comes from within and there's pressure
that is put on you by other's
expectations and i mean i i've always
said that the most pressure i feel is
the pressure that I put on myself you
know I want to be the best that I can be
and I want to perform so again it comes
back to confidence and self ability you
know self confidence and you know in
your ability if you if you believe in
yourself and you believe that you've
worked as hard as you possibly can and
you've done the things you need to do to
to get to the level you want to be out
you know the things that you want to
achieve then you shouldn't really feel
the pressure too much
rory mcilroy going for the green into
this from 268 yards
gave it a chance we've got somebody
who's reached the green and 2 and this
could be our first Eagle of the day
McIlroy to take advantage of the great
3-wood second shot
the watch I wear my heart on my sleeve
with my golf and you know if I play
badly it affects you know my mood I'm
sad and if I play well I'm happy and you
know sometimes I might be a little too
emotionally attached to my golf in terms
of how it affects my mood but it's not a
bad thing it shows passion it shows that
you want to do well but uh yeah I mean
everyone's going to have bad days and no
one's perfect and everyone's going to
make mistakes and you I accept that and
I accept it you know there is going to
be some days that are worse than others
but you know as long as you know you you
really relish that you know that the
highs and you you learn from those as
long as you learn from your mistakes but
you also have to learn from you know
from your victories as well and I feel
like I'm getting better than that
go over the corner of the bunker so he's
got a love to pull the way to the edge
of the green no option to run this the
tundra chip in
promise you I didn't know what sort of a
shot was that I don't believe this today
we never get a better days glove we're
not finished yet I have a habit of
getting ahead of myself and thinking
about what it would be like to lift the
Claret Jug or you know what will the
celebrations be like or who's going to
be at the 88th green to greet me so all
these thoughts I had to keep out of my
head
because going on with a six-shot lead
you know you know it's hard not to think
about that you know and especially when
people have already thought that you've
won people have already thought oh it's
over tis you know and you can't allow
yourself to think like that at all
so I had to stay in the present I had to
focus on each and every shot right there
I had my two little trigger words which
were process and spot and every time I
stood behind a golf shot today and I was
visualizing what I wanted to do with it
I kept a kalma tell myself process just
process process make a good decision
make a good swing the end result will
take care of itself
16
me
until you've tried to hook it off that
bunker he likes it
what's luck
how about him right over it Gary extreme
look at this extreme hunting eleven to
go over it isn't it where the people
have to walk across the crosswalk
yeah outraged that's outrageous hey
we've been here since day one of this of
this turn of a tent now in extent have
you ever seen it drive down that way
Gary no miss Eccles because you want to
achieve certain things in your life you
know whether it's golf for me or you
know whether its buying a house fur for
someone else or whether it's securing a
good job or have a family or whatever it
is there's many different reasons why
you set goals and I obviously have a lot
of goals for my career and I have a lot
of goals for my life as well but I think
it's important to set goals because it
means you don't get complacent you know
you always have something to aim for
you can set result-oriented goals where
you know it's a long-term goal or you
can you can set little short-term goals
to help you get to that long-term goal
so instead of saying I want to win the
Masters I'll say what will help me win
the Masters and what's I need to improve
to get there out to 11 at McIlroy second
this from 181 from the rough if you lie
here has got to try to keep it left of
the hole
he's gotten it up in the air nicely Oh
Roger
okay toughest hole on the course today
that was a shot that he's going to be
thrilled with the outcome
just after escaping to the surface the
fringe kind of planned with his uh
putted Stoke here Johnny let's see the
backstroke yeah 47 feet looking perky
darn gut just clears it out of the green
and turns it into a birdie wow that was
nice
do you have any advice for young golfers
looking to improve their game young
aspiring Rory McIlroy harms plenty okay
yeah I mean I obviously get asked this
question um I guess the big thing for me
is you have to keep enjoying putting
because once it starts to feel like a
job or feel like a chore then it's you
know that's when you have to step back
and take if it's really for you the one
thing that for me I never had anyone
pushing me it was always me it was
always coming from within that I wanted
I had that drive to go ahead and
practice and play and as long as they
enjoyed it in that and they enjoy the
solitude sometimes going out and hitting
balls on your own and being on your own
for quite long periods of time during
the day if they enjoy that and they feel
like it you know they're up for that
challenge each and every day then just
go out and do it and work hard and I
think a big thing is well don't let
don't let anyone tell you that you can't
absolutely you have to believe in
yourself and you if you believe in
yourself 100% and you can do anything
cool and you still enjoyed it
I am yeah I know you enjoy it yeah it is
good to see don't enjoy when I don't
play well what would I say destroy I
enjoy I enjoy the challenge of trying to
get better
well I think he's got to play this one
pretty low to make sure that it gets a
skid up
oh goodness he's just made something
that released a nine out of ten for
difficulty what is it that you see for
yourself what are your goals long term
as a business you see some golfers you
know you see the likes of Arnold Palmer
they see the likes of Jack Nicklaus and
you see they've built their brand over
the years and I think the most important
thing for an athlete is building their
brand on their performance on their
field whether it be on the golf course
or on the football pitch or the
basketball court or the tennis court or
whatever it is I think that's the
number-one thing right then can't do one
without the other
exactly you know so I think that's the
most important and then you know if you
do have that performance on the field or
on the golf course I think then it's a
point you know
having a great team around you and
knowing what you want to achieve and and
I think a lot of it is you know when
you're satisfied you know when are you
happy you know what are you ever going
to be satisfied or you know I think
that's something that's a big question
work for a lot of people
before I had 13-under bras a club back
splash sit out on a good line land short
of our leasing up to a torch company
rory mcilroy because the 15 under par
with a hole out eagle here at the toe
you know it's trying to be the best
golfer I can be but at the same time you
know not letting that take over my life
you know I want to still try and keep
somewhat of a normal life and you do the
things that any other 23 year old to do
so with a houseful of six fellas so it's
a it's good craic it's nice to have them
around because they're just really you
know taking everything in and enjoying
it and new they don't get to see what my
normal day is like all the time you know
they just sort of know me from back home
so you're not good for you as well yeah
it is it's great you know it's a great
you know I walked back into the house
yesterday and they're all in the back
garden in the jacuzzi chillin having a
few beers I was like I wish I could join
you voice
at the par-4 7th rory mcilroy hit driver
off the tee just 52 yards looking
straight down this flag little bump and
run from this long rough and what a shot
here what a shot
so McIlroy makes Eagle here at the seven
obviously if you have a lot of money you
have enough for yourself then that's
when you can start to give back to
people you find yourself in that stage
now where is that a little further out
in terms of the real philanthropy that
you want to do in your life I think that
might be a still a little further right
but I'm I'm definitely reaching that
stage where you know I feel like I've if
I keep playing the way I play I play on
the golf course I'm hopefully never
going to have to worry about about money
and then you know there might be a day
where you know I want to give you all up
back because I feel like the games given
me a lot and you know I'd love to give
some back here is McIlroy in his second
Roger hard to get it closer with her
right side job from anywhere but
particularly hard from this right side
of the fairway
it's rather than just left home
look how tough he is
[ __ ] Tiger was a huge hero of mine
growing up and to be able to play
against your hero nine and good on the
stretch and beat them sometimes and
hopefully beat them majority of the time
is it's a huge thrill for me you know I
didn't know if I'd ever get to do it and
you know I'm you know I someone you know
people ask me what what's it like you
know living this life what's it like to
be Rory McIlroy and I'm you know I'm
living like my dream this is what I've
always dreamed that fun I think it gets
any better than that
I should think lagging up for a powerful
about making it 10 under
big time
MacAvoy
there's a win and then there's an
absolute is a breakout or a blowout
performance because that's what we've
just watched you're gonna be watching
him for a long long time and you've
discovered him in many ways today in
Charlotte thank you so much for watching
we made this video because Jeff asked us
to if you have another entrepreneur you
want us to profile leave it in the
comments below we'd also love to know
which of Rory McIlroy's top 10 rules
meant the most to you at the biggest
impact leave in the comments and we'll
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching
can you to believe and we'll see you
soon thank you so much for watching oh
right oh that's all you say okay thank
you so much for watching we made this
video because Jeff asked us to if you
have another inspiration talking like a
motormouth thank you so much for
watching we made this video because Jeff
asked us to if you have another
entrepreneur you want us to profile
leave it in the comments below it's okay
we'll go with it what no no no go with
it not on this fine whatever just kind
of boring but it's fine